(slow, tender music)
(rhythmic beeping)
- The surgeon is real.
The tools are real.
The surgery is real.
The patient is artificial.
(playful music)
I took what I learned
from special effects,
and now I apply it to helping
kids here at the hospital.
(playful xylophone music)
My name is Gregory Loan,
and I'm a senior simulation
engineer at Boston Children's Hospital.
I make artificial patients
to allow real doctors
to practice procedures to
improve health outcomes for kids.
I do not think that I could do this work
without having had the experiences
that I had in special effects.
While I was working in special effects,
I got the opportunity to build dinosaurs
for the Jurassic Park theme parks
and magical creatures for Harry Potter
and all kinds of wonderful things
to bring that experience
to life for people.
I ultimately left special effects
to go focus in on robotics,
which is my other passion in life.
The best part is now I
combine special effects,
robotics, and engineering, and medicine
into a package that helps people.
I make simulation models.
Some of them are really low tech,
like an arm that you can inject
or practice line placement,
all the way up to and including
gunshot wound patients and
advanced surgical techniques,
like cleft lip repair.
At the end of the day, I know that
my contribution helps kids
because the creations that we make here
go towards saving children's lives.
- [Surgeon] And it looks
like we're about done.
(uplifting music)
(electronic pinging)